back we're going to be back in the game
it's not american alone
number one i've got had the opportunity
to speak
with now uh six world leaders um
and uh and the response has been
very fulsome energetic
president-elect joe biden talking about
his interactions with foreign leaders as
they
congratulate him congratulating him on
his election
joining us now to talk about foreign
policy now and in the future the
secretary of state of the united states
mike pompeo mr secretary thanks for the
time thank you brett thanks for having
me on this evening
so what do you say to world leaders who
are reaching out
to joe biden now the president-elect
leaders from
all kinds of countries belgium canada
estonia france
germany greece the list goes on even
saudi arabia which was president trump's
first stop
congratulating president-elect joe biden
from the king of saudi arabia
what do you say to them i'll actually be
in paris uh
monday and i'm headed to saudi arabia
after that there's still
an awful lot of work to do we're
reminding everyone that all the votes
haven't been counted
we need to make sure the legal process
is fully complied with and then america
will do what it does best
we'll have a leader in the white house
on noon on january 20th and we'll
continue to execute american foreign
policy it's what
president trump wants to make sure that
our entire team does all the way through
every day that's what we're focused on
is what i have my team focused on
there's still a lot going on in the
world we're pretty focused here in
america on
our own election there's a lot still
going on in the world and we're focused
on making sure we keep americans safe
during this time period
you know you were asked today about the
concerns about a smooth transition and
you said it will be a smooth transition
to a second
trump administration were you being
serious there
we'll have a smooth transition and we'll
see what the people ultimately decided
when all the votes have been cast we
have a
process bread the constitution lays out
how electors vote
it's a very detailed process laid out we
need to comply with all of that and then
i am very confident
that we will have a good transition that
we will make sure that whoever is in
office on noon on january 20th
has all the tools readily available so
we don't skip a beat
with the capacity to keep americans safe
that's what i was speaking to today
i think it's important for not only the
american people but the whole world
especially our adversaries to know that
we will achieve this in a way that's
deeply consistent with the american
tradition
and keeps us all safe here at home
understanding that we're following all
of the legal
ongoings in the various states and
you're right the electors aren't chosen
until december 14th
but there has been a concern in the past
about transitions that have been delayed
and that somehow on a national security
front that makes the u.s weaker at some
point
do you disagree with that i'm not
worried about that at all
i was part of a transition on the other
side i came into
an administration president obama's when
i was a cia director
uh we managed it we did it very
efficiently it didn't take as much time
as some might
be pretending that it's going to take i
i'm very confident that all the things
that need to be done will be done in an
appropriate way that we will deliver
that
and if i'm an adversary i would not
think for a moment that in this time
between now and january this
that was the moment that they might have
an opportunity it's simply not the case
uh president trump and our team
are on watch so that's my first question
is it improper for these foreign leaders
to be reaching out
to joe biden you know if they're just
saying hi
i suppose that's not too terribly
difficult but make no mistake about it
we have one president one secretary of
state
one national security team at a time
it's appropriate that it be that way
brad i will say this
one of the things that i have observed
now almost four years into my time in
this administration is the
previous folks just refused to get off
the stage so they they talk about
healing and all these transitional
things frankly i've watched
uh ben rhodes susan rice and john kerry
and wendy sherman
be active on the world stage in ways
that weren't consistent with what the
trump administration is doing
i regret that it wasn't in america's
best interest that they chose to behave
that way
for all the focus back at the beginning
of the trump administration
on incoming national security adviser
michael flynn
and his phone calls and the talk about
the logan act
are you worried that that is happening
now
i'm always worried when people are
engaging in activity speaking with
foreign leaders in a way
that represents things that might be
representing things that aren't true
or might be attempting to influence
american foreign policy in ways that are
inconsistent with what the law requires
you know the logan act i know the logan
act i hope that all those folks
who are out there having these
conversations aren't violating that law
i'm sure the department of justice will
be
keeping a good eye on that for us you
know foreign policy didn't get a ton of
coverage in the presidential election a
little bit
but what's your biggest concern with a
joe biden foreign policy
well i think america's biggest concern
ought to be that we'll return to a
policy of appeasement and
i think that i think the administration
used the term leading from behind
it's the antithesis of what president
trump has done we've been very realistic
whether that was moving the embassy to
jerusalem or taking down qasim sulaimani
and reducing the threat from iran or
recognizing for the first time in 40
years that the chinese communist party
presented an enormous threat
to the security of the american people
and frankly jobs and our american
economy
i think the things that the obama
administration did put americans in a
worse place
i think that people's jobs and lives
were less secure than they have been for
these past four years
and i hope that a president who comes
into office in the middle of january of
next year
will have a much more robust more
capable more
confident national security approach
than what they had for those eight years
which is the more imminent threat right
now iran russia
china bret those are hard questions to
answer and uh
i when i when i think about the
challenges that america has presented
over the next five or ten years the
chinese communist party is absolutely
the central threat
they are they're here they're
influencing the way we think about the
world they have technologies they're
very capable
they have stolen intellectual property
that's destroyed millions of
jobs in places like kansas and iowa and
michigan
in our heartland we cannot let that hap
continue to happen and president trump
has made real progress
in getting the world to recognize this
threat should joe biden be receiving the
presidential daily brief
the classified version i'll leave that
to others to sort out whether that's
appropriate or not
at this point you know when you say that
it's going to be a second trump
administration the president has tweeted
out
that this is a corrupt election that
democrats are trying to steal the
election from him
does it make it harder for the state
department in dealing with other
countries where we have tried to
say to them a democratic republic and
our way of voting
is the way to go you know that's a great
question brad i don't think that's the
case at all
in my time at the state department we
worked hard in countries all over the
world to help them build out election
infrastructure
to make sure that they had transparency
to make sure that they follow their own
rules their own systems that's all we're
asking for is to make sure that we
follow our own rules our own
constitution our own law
uh we have a transparent system one that
we need to keep pressing on
we need to make sure that uh every vote
that was legal is counted and those that
might not have been legal
aren't counted unless they were that's
what we ask in countries all across the
world i think they see us doing that i
actually think other countries
reflect on how america is proceeding
through this process and i think they're
encouraged by the fact
that the rule of law is something that
matters here it's something that we the
state department
encourage every nation across the world
to do
two more things one was some people were
surprised that your west point classmate
secretary esper was fired uh were you
mark mark's a good friend and mark has
served this nation both in his time
when we were cadets and his time in
uniform i i wish him well president gets
to choose those folks that he wants to
serve
and i'll i'll leave it there other than
to say i'm proud of the
work that the entire team that the
president has had for my four years has
accomplished
i'm hopeful we'll have more time to
continue to work to keep americans safe
you fought to have gina haspel at cia
the fbi director currently do you think
the president's going to make changes
there as well
i'll leave those decisions about people
to the president i'm focused on the
mission i'm focused on working with the
team
to make sure that we deliver on behalf
of the american people
okay last thing 2024 either way do you
have
aspirations politically either at the
highest office in the land
or a certain kansas senate seat that may
come open
brett you know me better than that i
appreciate you asking
but i i'm focused i'm focused on what
i'm doing today i'll
i'll keep at that well mr secretary we
appreciate your time and we'll check
back in before january 20th
that sounds great brett thank you sir